It is part of the LGBTIQ plus community this information is for you
Spain is par excellence the territory that allows people who love
equally be free I give you several options so you can vigrate that you
can form 1 family Madrid Barcelona Tenerife and other provinces have
their door totally open for you to live freely You have 1 boyfriend 1
girlfriend You want to meet again 1 person you love You will be able to
have it through 1 community family card process this will provide you
with 1 residence 1 work authorization for the first
5 years For this to be carried out,
it is to demonstrate that this relationship or bond is really true.
Before emigrating you must keep in mind the following you must
bring the required documents to be regular birth certificate
criminal record proof of residence in your country of origin this
will help you to advance 1 little the process especially to have 1
legality as before extra legal Your best legal option in Spanish territory.